♪ ♪ ♪
- Gert-Jan Bleeker
est infirmier et fier de l'être.
Il travaille pour Alerimus,
une des entreprises privées
auxquelles le gouvernement
néerlandais fait appel pour
fournir les soins à domicile
aux personnes âgées.
Des personnes parfois très
malades, comme Lenn Verm 9 9 90
ans, qui souffre d'insuffisance
cardiaque et respiratoire et qui
vit seul dans sa petite maison.
Monsieur Vermaas est considéré
comme un patient en fin de vie.
Les infirmiers lui rendent
visite deux fois par jour
et il peut communiquer avec eux
en tout temps en cas d'urgence.
La petite équipe de Gert-Jan,
qui compte qe e e infirmières,
prend soin d'une cinquantaine
de patients.
Certains sont vus plusieurs
fois par jour, comme cette dame,
atteinte de ieieieurs maladies
et qui, jusqu'à tout récemment,
cohabitait avec un mari atteint
de démence.
Son mari est maintenant
hospitalisé. Elle reçoit de
l'aide psychologique une fois
par semaine, en plus des visites
quotidiennes des infirmiers.
Les infirmiers sont en contact
avec un médecin, qui intervient
au besoin.
La docteure Veldhoen se rend
aussi parfois chez les patients
âgés, mais elle compte beaucoup
sur le personnel infirmier
pour évaluer les besoins
et faire les suivis requis.
Le suivi des patients peut
se faire par visioconférence.
Avec cette femme, par exemple,
qui souffre d'un début de
démence et qui vit seule.
L'équipe d'infirmiers compte
aussi sur sa fille, qui habite
à proximité.
Alerimus gère un centre de jour
où les patients qui vivent seuls
à la maison peuvent socialiser
une ou deux fois par semaine.
Tous les soins à la maison et
toutes les activités sociales
pour les personnes âgées sont
financés par l'État néerlandais
et par un régime d'assurance
parmi les plus généreux au
monde.
y y y a presque deux fois moins
de lits pour aînés dans les
centres de soins publics aux
Pays-Bas comparativement au
Québec. Le maintien à domicile
permet d'économiser
des sommes considérables,
mais c'est d'abord une question
delololosophie et de mentalités
qui explique cette différence,
nous dit cette chercheure.
Monsieur Sanders ne pourrait
pas vivre à la maison s'il était
seul. Il est presque totalement
dépendant de sa femme qui,
à 75 ans,  se demande combien de
temps elle pourra encore tenir.
- Ici, c'est bien parce qu'on
peut rester dans la maison.
C'est pas facile de trouver une
place quand on a besoin d'une
maison pour les handicapés ou
des vieilles personnes, parce
que là, ils ont pleins, pleins,
pleins. Et là, c'est pourquoions
longtemps dans la maison,
avec l'aide, comme maintenant.
- C'est un peu l'envers de la
médaille. L'État néerlandais
manque de places pour accueillir
les personnes qui ne sont plus
autonomes. Il faut un peu plus
de centres de soins, oui, mais
surtout plus d'infirmières sur
le terrain, nous ditmémémédecin.
Les Pays-Bas sont eux aussi
aux prises avec un manque
criant de personnel infirmier.
Si on construisait plus
de centres, on manquerait
de personnel pour les faire
fonctionner. La solution réside
donc dans une approche
communautaire, selon cette
professeure.